on va passer maintenant à l'info en plus
travailler les travail on en parlait
dans le dernier filet qu il s'agit d'une
forme d'organisation de travail qui
permet via les technologies de
l'information d'effectuer son activité
professionnelle en dehors des bureaux de
son entreprise ou de son client par
exemple de chez soi une association exo
france a réagi à notre reportage nous a
proposé de découvrir un avantage au
télétravail auxquelles nous n'avions pas
forcément pensé je vous propose de
découvrir avec un des membres de cette
association de quoi il s'agit le
télétravail commence à se faire
connaître en france parmi les avantages
moins de temps de transport ou encore
une meilleure organisation de son temps
l'association exo france y voit surtout
un moyen d'intégrer des personnes
handicapées pour aborder ce sujet nous
retrouvons tiago de once prat le
responsable évinois 17 associations
bonjour alors finalement pourquoi le
télétravail peut être peut être une
solution alors le télétravail permet de
rendre compatibles des impératifs de
santé des impératifs de handicap avec
les obligations professionnelles il
s'agit pour des personnes qui ont des
maladies chroniques ou des handicaps
particuliers qui ne peuvent pas se
rendre quotidiennement d'entreprise
d'apporter le travail chez eux
je pense que l'insertion des personnes
inquiétées si elle passe par quelque
chose c'est par l'emploi c'est un lacet
l'emploi qui va créer un réseau social
c'est l'emploi qui va créer de ce qui va
permettre de créer des amitiés et c'est
l'emploi qui réussirent la personne
c'est l'emploi qui permet son soutien
financier
son insertion sociale par la possibilité
de se payer un logement etc etc c'est
finalement la loi française oblige les
sociétés de plus de 20 salariés
d'embaucher 6 % de travailleurs
handicapés sous peine d'amendé on sait
que c'est finalement peu suivi alors en
quoi le télétravail pourrait changer la
donne
effectivement on sait qu'il ya plus de
20 % de personnes handicapées au chômage
que
l'obligation d'emploi des postes de
travail et handicapés n'est pas
respectée ni par le public ni par le
privé d'ailleurs la fonction publique
donne un très mauvais exemple alors
l'intérêt pour l'entreprise dans ce que
nous proposons et vient plutôt du visio
travail le visio travail permet de
rassurer les employeurs parce que il ya
un lien constant
un échange par webcam qui es tu peux
être permanente et qui permet aux à
l'employeur et l'employé de se voir
constamment pour l'employé de si ça se
présente un avantage puisque sa limite
l'isolément éventuels qui peut survenir
dans la pratique du télétravail au
quotidien mais il ya plein de solutions
qui peuvent être envisagées
on peut envisager un télétravail
pendulaires donc une partie à la maison
ça peut être une partie en télécentres
et sap est une partie ont envie de
travail tel que nous le proposons nous
ce que nous appelons le visio travail
ces couples et le télétravail avec une
webcam et un système de type cloud donc
avec un serveur sécurisé avec un partage
de données qui sont sécurisées et qui
peuvent éventuellement être reprise par
un autre télétravailleurs seelandais
d'être télétravailleurs était défaillant
pour une période de nuit ce qui est
parfois le cas avec une personne
handicapée de personnel chronique c'est
ce que vous proposez dans votre
association finalement une utilisation
les pratiques voilà c'est du télé
travail collaboratif avec un système de
visiophonie
on a un condensé sens
interrogé télétravail mais en gros ça
représente juste une pratique différente
du télétravail mais qui est par contre à
sur les employeurs puisque effectivement
s'il ya un souci finalement un autre
salarié pourra prendre le relais ça ne
reste possible que pour certaines
activités
c'est certain c'est certain souvent pour
des prestations plutôt d'ordre
intellectuel qui peuvent être réalisées
à distance mais de plus en plus nos
métiers au quotidien ses seins pour
rédiger un rapport pour faire la
comptabilité voir il ya plein de métiers
qui peuvent être exercés à distance et
même des métiers pour lesquels la
logique voudrait qu'on est face à
distance je pense par exemple les
webmasters il ya aucune raison qu'ils se
re qui se retrouve à faire des
déplacements à faire la population comme
andy jusqu'au lieu de travail alors que
justement leur lieu de travail c'est
internet
donc autant être logique et ne pas
imposer à cette personne d'aller polluer
obligés de leur faire perdre de temps
alors qu'elles peuvent le faire de chez
elle votre association ils essayent de
faire connaître ce mode de travail mais
vous avez également des actions
concrètes
voilà on essaye notamment en ce moment
de lancer un programme qui s'appelle
crowdsourcing pré emploi solidaire où on
en est
ce titre qui s'appelle le club de
service du handicap l'idée c'est de
mutualiser des commandes d'unités
horaires pour créer un emploi donc le
but est de créer un emploi à partir de
plusieurs commandes horaire par exemple
si un employeur a besoin de 4 5 heures
de téléphonie par semaine et qu'un autre
employeur également besoin de téléphonie
ou un autre type de secrétariat
on va essayer de cumuler ces différentes
demandes et de créer un poste pour une
personne adaptée pas forcément un temps
plein mais au moins à 20 heures
évidemment et donc les pré emploi
solidaire ont été lancés il ya un peine
un mois une cvthèque est en ligne sur
leur site internet
exo france planète voilà on continue on
va parler de des emplois d'avenir à 10
oui disent que créa attrape le maire à
signer une convention ville état
allant dans ce sens en présence de
benoît hamon donc ministre délégué
chargé l'économie sociale et solidaire
vendredi dernier trois jeunes sont déjà
recruté un agent de service de la voie
publique
un aide techniciens du spectacle et un
manutentionnaire
il s'agit d'un contrat d'un an couplée
d'une formation dans leur domaine
spécifique la direction maintenant
vélizy puisqu'à une convention sécurité
qui a été signé entre l'état et le
centre commercial vélizy 2 c'était donc
ce matin vous souhaitez c'était ce matin
et c'est une première dans les yvelines
cette convention qui est issu d'un plan
national lancé en 2010 permet une
meilleure coopération ou par exemple un
partenariat entre la police et l'équipe
de la sécurité du centre des lettres
plainte pour éviter de se rendre au
commissariat ou encore une
uniformisation des procédures
le directeur du centre nous en dit un
peu plus on les écoute on va parler de
communication quand on appelle la police
et quand on décrit un événement est ce
qu'on a le bon protocole est ce qu'on a
les bons verbatim est ce que le message
est bien passé est-ce qu'on n'oublie pas
de l'information quand la police arrive
et ce qu'ils ont bien les informations
la localisation de l'événement s'ils
connaissent bien le centre voilà c'est
toutes ces questions aujourd'hui qui
sont déjà acquises mais qu'on va
continuer
vraiment officialisé et a vraiment un
style comme une feuille de route qui au
fur et à mesure des années et des
générations passées on va pouvoir
effectivement à faire évoluer
alors cette convention vise surtout à
renforcer les liens existants
en deux ans les interventions au centre
vélizy 2 ont diminué de 25 % ça reste à
noter et chaque année 15 millions de
personnes
ils vont faire leurs achats